[Music]
hey everybody yeah like I said this is
our new gonna be our new matinee format
you know instead of doing three movies
at one time we're just gonna do each
movie you know individually just because
we thought that would be better for
putting content up every day instead of
having to do side tracks every day and
also easier for people to search if
they're just looking for one particular
movie they don't have to like yeah you
go through three different boys you know
what I mean
so it just made more sense so to that
and the first one we're gonna be
reviewing this week is actually sort of
a movie and sort of a series kind of
yeah this is a shutter exclusive a
shutter original and it's called blood
machines and this is this [ __ ] is
fantastic it was I like this series
beautiful this is the way the new Flash
Gordon should be this this series was a
synthesis of [ __ ] high tech [ __ ]
entertainment in terms of visuals
psychedelic and [ __ ] schlock it's
like the acting is not that good the the
story is okay it's not bad the visuals
and certain ideas are [ __ ] I liked it
yeah that was off off the charts I had
the feeling out and and it's like it's a
trip it's like something out of Mandy it
looks like something from Mandy the same
color palette there was some really in
it really some some interesting ideas in
this very original [ __ ] like blasters
that shoot a beam and the beam stays
there for a long time yeah as an
aftereffect and [ __ ] high tech
blasters that don't really work that
well they're they're you know they're
they're [ __ ] they're unreliable yeah
they're kind of a used future yeah yeah
I liked it but visually the thing was
just [ __ ] stunning yeah this is my
mother [ __ ] Mandy this is one of the
most mind-blowing ly gorgeous yeah
visual like feasts for the eyes that I
have ever seen and the music the music
and the music is amazing
it's like new retro way of music but
yeah what can really know you're really
into new retro waves that aesthetic and
that music and stuff like that you will
just be orgasmic at this because this is
like that but like ramped up to like a
thousand and there's kind of like a
b-movie feel to the acting but it's like
a good b-movie feel it's like this movie
was made by people that cared about it
and we're like you know making it
themselves but it's weird to see that
just to suppose but when you get older
you you can't [ __ ] enunciate it you
see kind of like amateurish qualities
along with like really expert qualities
the kind of monument reminded me of the
way like the first Star Wars movie yeah
you know where it was kind of brilliant
but also kind of homemade feel to it at
the same time it was just good man I
liked it the story had some stuff in
there that to me it kind of felt like
this male versus female theme which is
kata getting her over over in real
common nowadays and a lot of these
movies which come I'm getting sick of
that you know I mean I'd rather see men
and women working together to overcome
something instead of trying to [ __ ] each
other over I just think it's tired but
aside from that it was still had some
original concepts well and I don't think
it was so much that I think they weren't
like they weren't like so much going
after the men is that one man in
particular because he was a douche canoe
yeah I don't know though because the way
I read the story it looked like all the
men had turned most of the women into
machines and then the women that weren't
machines were kind of like scavenging
rebels remember that he went in there
and captured him I think that was the
normal state of a state of being for for
the futures what they're kind of saying
which kind of reminds me that was like
something kind of like out of the dune
expanded universe with the books where
there was one one civilization that was
a religion
that where they become so [ __ ]
uptight and anti-sexual that they turned
the women into clowns that didn't have
arms legs or heads so they didn't have
any consciousness they were just used as
breeding vessels for more men because
they didn't yeah you know I mean which
is like and it was kind of like a
situation like that I think based on
what they were showing me all the men
had enslaved all the women by turning
them into machines and one of them broke
free and they they run after it and it
goes to a damn cosmic junk pile and then
that [ __ ] female soul [ __ ] gets
inside that machine into that old
wrecked machine and somehow replicates
itself into a thousands of little tiny
women that all combined into one giant
woman
it's [ __ ] that it's like imagine the
Death Star's a woman yes trippy it's a
tree trippy like in a journey like I I
don't know like if you did acid and
watch this it's like I kind of felt like
I was on acid watching it actually but
yeah the way the way that they did it
okay so I don't know um how well-known
this is or anything like that but this
movie I call it a movie even though it's
three it's in three parts and those
parts are only about 20 minutes long and
they have like full like opening credits
and end credits which is fine with me
because like the end credits have all
the music and the music is rad yeah but
um so so even if you put it all together
as one movie I think it would only be
like an hour long maybe not even an hour
but I'm you know I'm not sure why they
chose to do it like that other than I
mean it doesn't really matter you know I
think what the thing is okay so this is
directed by a person which is not really
a person but their name is Seth xyn I
think or a Kherson it's actually two
guys it's like a French filmmaking team
and I guess they had hooked up with this
quote-unquote band called carpenter brut
which is actually just one dude also and
they had directed a music video for
carpenter brut called turbo killer which
is on YouTube and you can watch it
they did a bunch of other ones too he
did a bunch of other ones and one of
them I can't remember what the [ __ ] it
was called leather teeth or something
like that actually had bits of like the
Lucci of Ulchi movie murder Rock in it
which I thought was very funny but he's
like a lot of like Italian horror
imagery like in there [ __ ] so I guess
they directed him that music video and
in that music video um a lot of the
concepts and visuals and character
designs like for this for blood machines
were introduced like so you get like the
naked women with the upside down glowing
crosses on their stomachs and like all
the shapes and like the ships and stuff
so it's almost kind of like this movie
is sort of like a sequel to the music
video kind of except this actually has a
story I mean I guess the video kind of
does too but the video I mean it's just
a music video but this is kind of like a
continuation of it the way I took it
because of my age really I think
probably is that this was kind of like
something lifted out it out of a
magazine we used to have a long time ago
called heavy metal yeah it looks a bit
like that too and heavy metal was like a
sci-fi slash [ __ ] magazine it was all
hand Illustrated I didn't know it but
one time I was a little kid out San
Diego and I ran across one of the real
famous artists he was a friend of red
you know my uncle red yeah he knew one
of the guys and I saw I walked into his
room and saw these storyboards these
awesome [ __ ] alien ships and [ __ ]
that he was making and I found out later
that that guy was one of the guys that
regularly did drawings for good but
anyway um it looked like something out
of heavy metal to where heavy metal was
cool because you know there might be a
story that might last three or four
magazines and then it dropped out you
never saw it again
yeah and the stories were like this yeah
I mean it was that same kind of tone and
they looked some of them looked like
this so I know it's foreign but maybe
they were influenced by something that
they saw in heavy metal magazine or the
war yeah I'm sure Tom that's really kind
of seeped into the popular yeah I think
yeah I'm the tone of it is very much
like heavy metals yeah it gave me a
little bit of um maybe because of like
the naked space woman thing too gave me
a little bit of a life force vibe yeah
um some parts of it even gave me like a
2001
type of thing alien ones like especially
like later in the movie because this it
does have a plot in the sense that you
know there's a ship called the Mima and
it lands on this what they think is I
guess there's like a rogue AI which
turns out to be this naked woman she's
like an entity I guess yeah she's a soul
yeah she's like a soul she's not like a
person right and um so she's gone broke
and I guess the ship which has like this
one the douchey captain and like this
old guy on it who's actually pretty cool
and then they have like this female
robot like I guess she's a navigation
robot yeah but I think she was a cyborg
yes she might have been she looks she
just learning about yeah it was hard to
tell because but there was like a mesh
between you know between the machines
and the people because like like one of
the ships of one of the ships that
crashed that belonged to some of the
scavengers or something or she was
trying to like fix it yeah it was like a
living being or it had a soul inside it
yeah and they called it a woman and
that's where that thing came from yeah
that's where that soul came from yeah
she came out of that [ __ ] and and the
shit's like had blood coming out of it
like yeah blood machines yeah but that's
what so it was like a really cool like
concept of like a living machine or at
least a machine with a living soul like
sort of a human soul or a cosmic
consciousness or something like that
like inside of it that also bled like a
person like and that was how it was
powered you know I mean that was kind of
what I got out of it anyway but so you
know so it does kind of set that up but
a lot of stuff isn't explained it
doesn't really need to be and as as the
you know chapters go on there's like
less and less dialogue and it just kind
of becomes more like this big like
metaphorical like space opera in a sense
is what it is because it's basically
just like these mind-blowing visuals and
like this really really awesome music so
it is calm almost kind of like a music
video but it does have a story and it
doesn't apply in characters and dialogue
and stuff but not I mean it's definitely
very experimental and the to I guess the
two guys I think they got the money for
this on Kickstarter and I think this is
self contained I don't know if they're
gonna make another one or any other
that was the only but there's really
only two things that I didn't like about
it there weren't enough episodes and it
seems to be that the story is over
although I could continue a story I
could I could I could well this seems
like a universe that you could expand
yes big time you can expand after this I
mean there could should be a follow-up
to this yeah I mean like it way it
wasn't totally resolved just that one
little adventure was yeah I mean this
was just like one little [ __ ] right one
tiny thing that happened in this like
one space like one place in the universe
or whatever the other thing is the other
thing I didn't like about it which I
already mentioned mentioned is that a
[ __ ] I got a kind of a weird sexism
vibe to it and I think a lot of guys are
starting to get sensitive to this
because a lot of movies have come out
over the past 15 years that seem very
much anti-men and again and and like
portraying all men as monsters and
there's a lot of guys online that are
making whole videos about this so like
man hey [ __ ] stop [ __ ] would do its
you know I mean dudes are not evil you
know no more than people like anybody
else you know but I don't know if that's
what the intent was or if that there
were that subject is getting so loaded
now that guys automatically start
interpreting it that way I think it's
the latter on yeah
because I mean you could I guess if you
wanted to you could interpret it that
that way but I didn't see it like that I
just I saw it as they were going after
the captain because he was a dick
particularly he because they were nice
they were nice to the old guy because he
was a nice guy well he knew about souls
or he believed that's what I mean so it
wasn't so much a man/woman thing it was
more like the spiritual thing versus
like a materialism but based on what
their boss told them and what his report
back to the the dick the [ __ ] I
forgot what his name was
Barkin or Vargas minding like that based
on what he's told his boss there was
this is this is the way things were yeah
yeah not I mean I guess it wasn't always
that way the older guy didn't seem to be
too hip on it but then again he did
[ __ ] try to attack the other female
robot the AI robot she said you never
raised your hand to me yeah so I you
know I mean I there I think there was a
[ __ ] a Hall
war between the sexes theme in this but
like you said they probably they might
have pulled that because that's kind of
a common thread going back in some
sci-fi for like a really long time like
you said it was even like in some of the
dune expanded universe that type of
thing so I don't know I'm not I'm not
like overly sensitive about that kind of
thing it doesn't really bother me all
that much that whole war between the
sexist thing the only only story I like
to but that was like that was that one
black mirror episode called booze a
gadfly effect that wasn't with black
mirror that was the Masters of Horror
masters and it was this crew flash
crucified what's gone the screw flies
solution oh yeah that thing was badass
man were the alien I was masters of
horror
Nash's a [ __ ] okay the aliens put some
kind of a [ __ ] bioweapon on the earth
to get the men to hate women yeah they
killed them all
yeah and they did it to wipe out the
human race and then when the aliens
showed up the men wouldn't fight the
aliens yeah remember that was weird no
they were just like hey how you doing
they'd walk up to him and it was based
on you know how humans humans have
insecticides that do that that's yeah
that's what that's why I mean that was
the point they were making is that what
if somebody took that and used it on
them yeah you guys haven't seen that man
you need to see that one masters afore
it used to be on Hulu but I haven't
watched it in a long time I thought it
was black mirror but yeah it's old it
was old yeah well I should know because
I did a couple years ago on my blog I
did a whole breakdown of every single
episode of Masters of Horror so yeah
that was a great anniversary so I
remember that was like that one
topped like all the BET that one was up
there like some of the best of the
Twilight zones that's how good that one
was for me it was a really good scared
me I was like oh [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] weird yeah well cuz
that's not crazy because like you said
that that is a thing that happens like
in some parts of the animal kingdom
yeah and it's when it begins they start
talking about it on the news yeah that
for some reason women are showing up
dead and then like in you know in like
Saudi Arabia they're doing mass
executions of women for breaking
religious taboos and then all of a
sudden men just start [ __ ] killing
all the women
and then covering up each other's crimes
yeah and just hunting down women with
guns and [ __ ] [ __ ] and then they're
protecting the boys remember that
they're treating boys like girls yeah
yeah that's [ __ ] bizarre and then at
the end the aliens show up and they just
walked walked towards him hey how are
you doing the aliens just [ __ ] kill
him yeah and then turn him into a little
gelatin cube and was feeding it to the
animals yeah that's right because they
just wanted the earth yeah they didn't
want they just want humans on it they
wanted to take it yeah it's there like
they thought they would just do the easy
it's one good thing yeah they just
converted all the humans into food yeah
yeah well that's probably I feel good
that bio recycled him back into the dam
yeah into the into the ecosystem but
yeah I mean this one like I said I
didn't because I didn't get the sense
that I mean yeah this is the couple
scavengers that you saw were women like
when was a younger woman and what was an
older woman they kind of reminded me of
like the vu bellini from Mad Max fury
road um a little bit like that but it's
like I got the feeling that even though
like the souls of the you know ships and
I guess the machines look like women but
they were like like I said there were
Souls and I and I I got the sense that
it was kind of like they made them look
like women because women are more like
you know oh Earth and Planetary like
life-giving and everything like that so
I thought they were going like a more
mythological kind of route that's not no
that's a kind of I don't know kind of
also kind of reminded me of the Riddick
series yeah but you just that looked a
lot better than Britain this is honestly
this is one of the most like at Bar None
this is one of the most visually
beautiful things I have ever seen it's I
mean you could just watch it you don't
even need the [ __ ] I mean you know
listen to it cuz the music is [ __ ]
epic too but you could just like [ __ ]
put it on and just over and over again
and it's just like yeah you could just
like spend years like picking all these
little details and these fabulous colors
and all those other yeah color palettes
very similar to what you saw in Mandy
yeah and it looks all [ __ ] high-tech
but then they aged it and made it look
like it was shot on film yeah it's like
retro futuristic a futurist so it looks
like an old movie but it looks like a
new movie
yeah if that makes any sense yes you
know what I mean it was neat like if you
were this is the way I imagined if you
were changed to color palette from that
purple and black and gold or purple
black and what was yeah purple black and
orange it was kind of what the color
palette if you were to change it from
that to like gold and black and red
that's the way I picture a new Flash
Gordon would look yeah imagine if this
was in Flash Gordon motif
it would have been honestly if these if
they let these two guys like these two
filmmakers make Flash Gordon that thing
would look [ __ ] a bit yeah because
this looks really [ __ ] cool yeah I
mean just all the ships and you could
tell like I mean obviously pretty much
most of it I imagine a CGI other than
like you know the people and everything
but it just it looks like CGI but not in
a bad way because I guess because they
age they made the film look kind of aged
so it looked like an old sci-fi movie
but then it was kind of like just these
really really super saturated reds and
greens and blues and like everything is
like you know black was like all these
like really brilliant like lights and
all this kind of [ __ ] it's like every
single frame looks like like a pane of
painting it's like it's really be an
analogue looking it doesn't look digital
to me and you know like I said I liked
that they had like all of their like the
ship that the two guys are on the Mima
was kind of like nothing worked you know
what I mean like everything was kind of
rickety and they were like having to
whack stuff together work John a
horseshoe-shaped a little bit like the
[ __ ] ship from alien Honda but more
mechanical it looked like I had a bunch
of saw blades and teeth yeah like almost
like a yeah and it's like organic and
the the bridge kind of stuck out and
look like a hat got clear look like the
head of a praying mantis kind of clear
bubble [ __ ] glass that he could look
out of and when it whenever it was
sitting on the ground landing it's just
dripping with water your Lord [ __ ] this
water coming from they didn't matter
it's just some kind of weird technology
that they had
yeah cuz like I said it appeared that
that because the catechol yeah it
appeared that they ran on blood or
something and there was even like a
thing like we're one of the scavenger
women like she drank oil at some point
or because they kept that guy kept
calling her oil drinker or oil and
something it's just something weird they
just make it there's making up their own
universe I thought it was very original
it really was I mean it's it's really
just the look of it alone and the
soundtrack and [ __ ] like that just like
knock my socks off so if you don't um
you should get shudder anyway because
we're always saying that if you don't
have shudder then go on youtube and
watch go look up carpenter brut you know
be our UT and they have a video on there
called turbo killer which was directed
by the same guys and it's kind of like
it's not as baroque and elaborate as the
movie is but it's a similar kind of look
so if you dig that and you dig the music
and [ __ ] like that cuz they have a bunch
of videos on YouTube I looked then you
should definitely get shudder and watch
this because this [ __ ] is amazing and I
just I can't wait to see like what they
do next like you said what if they give
me Flash Gordon that would be so [ __ ]
yeah look Flash Gordon 40th anniversary
right or is it 50 at that 40th
anniversary is coming up about 1984 TF
40th anniversary is coming up there's
gonna be a special blu-ray type release
or 4k release and they're doing doom and
this new doom is gonna come out and if
this new doom does well which I think it
will chances are they'll probably gonna
start looking at Flash Gordon because
you know Dino De Laurentiis did both of
those yeah and the audience for [ __ ]
Flash Gordon is now all my age and a lot
people don't realize how awesome Flash
Gordon was to see it in on the big
screen and you know in HD you know like
after I saw it and it's great and you
know in the theaters like mad as [ __ ] it
was awesome it was a kid you know and
then I saw at home I'm da Ches and I was
like bad thing looks terrible but if you
see it on blu-ray now on a [ __ ] good
TV it looks like it did in the big
screen that had awesome costumes you
know it was a movie of its time
but in some ways it was ahead of its
time too you know sex and drugs and it's
kind of illicit [ __ ] perpetually
horny [ __ ] princess [ __ ] Valera
whatever name was know uh was her name I
forgot I remember yeah means daughter
and just just a [ __ ] hot movie I
liked it
well I yes I I tend to like anything
with that like gorgeous like
over-the-top like saturated yeah color
scheme it's why I'm like everything was
opulent in Flash Gordon
yeah that's why and that's why I loved
this movie and that's why I love like
Dario Argento's early doings and stuff
like that just guy just really really
loved these kind of visual paintings
yeah and now I mean nowadays with
[ __ ] CG you could do Flash Gordon
[ __ ] just like you did this movie but
with with this little series mix it with
like Aquaman and flash gordon cuz
aquaman kind of Flash Gordon vibe to it
to me you know just it was underwater
instead of space but you could do a
mind-blowing [ __ ] Flash Gordon yeah
but my flash cards got to be emotional
it's not scientific you got a man you
it's it's it's an outerspace movie where
you could open the [ __ ] doors of the
spaceship and run down the wing and
still be able to breathe
ya know outer space in Mago yeah yeah
that I mean outer space is cheap and you
can breathe it and there's look at you
say it's in like a big [ __ ] dome or
something and it's in there's an up and
down yeah and planets aren't round some
of them are just a piece of the planet
there's a top and a bottom because they
didn't worry about this is [ __ ] 1920s
like 1930 space you know but like I said
I feel like maybe you probably nowadays
people are more open-minded particularly
consumer you know concerning sci-fi and
fantasy I think people are more willing
to like roll with an idea yeah it
doesn't have to be entirely realistic in
Dino's flick they go through some kind
of a vortex an imperial vortex to end up
in [ __ ]
so I guess mongos another dimension yeah
so you can explain everything and there
were you know Birdman were flying with
wings from one planet to the next yeah
there were clouds in space yeah you know
so that's another dimension that's how
you explain that [ __ ] away
yeah but yeah definitely um you know
like I said get shudder just so you can
see well they have a bunch of [ __ ] ton
of other like awesome content on there
as well but you know I really think this
needs to get seen more drop some acid
watch this [ __ ] it'll blow your [ __ ]
mind you might even need that really
because it's just like it's it looks
like a [ __ ] acid trip like on [ __ ]
screen and also the music like I said
it's completely red it really really
like new retro wave type stuff yeah you
will love this it's like amazing but
yeah definitely definitely checked out
and check out carpenter boots videos on
YouTube they have a whole bunch and I
think there's a bunch on Vimeo to this
because they did like a lot of erotica
and gore and stuff so they put that
those ones over on yeah get ready
because the acting is kind of bad but it
works yeah it's it works bad it's just a
little amateurish yeah honestly I think
the guy that plays the Demming is on
purpose
it might have been well just plus the
guy that plays the [ __ ] I have a
feeling that maybe English wasn't his
first language he sounds Dutch or German
it actually reminded me a lot of like a
really really well done star crash
remember star crash yeah or battle
beyond the stars
yeah like that yeah it doesn't seem like
you weren't really supposed to take us
seriously you were just supposed to trip
out on it like yeah it like reading
heavy metal yeah yeah so basically this
is kind of the same thing it's just kind
of like just sit back and just let it
like unfold before it is it's like
really really amazing and
gorgeous-looking
you